Sunday marks 20 years since the start of
operation Iraqi Freedom the U.S led
Invasion that toppled Saddam Hussein the
military operation was launched without
U.N support unlike the first Gulf War or
the invasion of Afghanistan our
diplomatic editor James Bays looks at
how The Invasion damaged The credibility
of the United Nations
U.N weapons inspectors in Iraq their job
to track down the country's chemical and
biological weapons we now know there
weren't any the former Iraqi ruler
Saddam Hussein had ceased his wmd
program years earlier but in 2003 U.S
President George Bush backed by the
British Prime Minister Tony Blair was
saying he was hiding a huge stockpile
and they claimed they had the
intelligence to prove it
U.S Secretary of State Colin Powell now
known to have been privately skeptical
himself tried to make the case in the
security Council even wielding a vial he
said could be anthrax the U.S and UK
bitterly opposed by much of the
International Community including France
and Germany failed to get a security
Council resolution to authorize a war
they launched one anyway
in the aftermath one British Diplomat
who'd worked as his country's expert on
Iraq in the security Council resigned do
you think the United Nations ended up
damaged or strengthened by the war 20
years ago I think without doubt it was
damaged by it the Secretary General of
the United Nations didn't assert his
authority to say that the war was
illegal and should not happen which
later he admitted and I think
collectively the quote unquote U.N this
sense of a global community of Nations a
sense of a shared set of rules took a
very big hit as a result of the Iraq War
so where does that leave things now 20
years on once again the Security Council
is deeply divided and there's no doubt
that the invasion of Ukraine by Russia a
permanent member was a breach of
international law and of the UN Charter
but Western diplomats when you speak to
them privately will tell you that their
efforts to put pressure on Moscow are
even now hindered by the memory of what
happened two decades ago
the run-up to the war in Iraq in 2003
was marked by Defiance and
disinformation resulting in deep damage
to the U.N system and the rule of law
around the world so much may have
changed since but the repercussions of
events that haunted the UN then are
still being felt James Bay's Al Jazeera
of the United Nations so let's bring in
Faisal al-is trabadi he's a former Iraqi
Diplomat and founding director of the
center for the study of the Middle East
at Indiana University joins us live from
Bloomington Faisal good to have you with
us so look the legacy of the Iraq War I
think is very much still being decided
still being written but do you think the
invasion by the U.S led Coalition was a
success or a disappointing failure
well it was a little bit of both uh it
has been uh disappointing to those of us
who went back to Iraq after spending
years in Exile to try to rebuild the
country to realize that the forces armed
against us were a little brother
stronger than we had anticipated and I
myself made the decision that there was
no particular point in my continuing so
I I resigned as Ambassador and left
um but on the other hand uh a brutal
Tyrant one who had terrorized his own
people killing hundreds upon hundreds of
thousands of Iraqi civilians and who had
invaded two uh neighboring states was
removed and that will be remembered I
think by history as an absolute good
okay so so what about Iraq today I mean
many Iraqis still see the political
system as deeply corrupt the sectarian
divide between Sunni and Shia remains
problematic militias still roam around
so has real political and economic
progress been made for ordinary Iraqis
on the streets
uh not what should have been made no uh
the economic problems of the country
have not begun to be addressed by any of
the successive governments
um and that's deeply uh problematic
um unfortunately we have a uh
governing system which favors the
sectarian divisions that the political
class has benefited from uh if you speak
to ordinary Iraqis in the street you
will find they're not nearly as divided
as their political class but the system
drives it's sort of the the governing
system is Iraq is almost a living
organism which has its own drive to
survive and that is uh deeply
problematic but what the Iraqis have
today that they did not have 20 years
ago is hope that the future will be
better than it was if the Americans and
their allies had not removed Saddam
either he or one of his two sons would
be ruling Iraq today Faisal you're a
former Iraqi Diplomat and you've
represented Iraq at the U.N many experts
say look at the say the U.N at the time
failed to exercise its Authority and
stand up to the US and the UK and saying
the war was illegal how much damage did
this do to The credibility of the United
Nations do you think
well there's a couple of things to keep
in mind first of all on the 8th of 2002
the security Council passed resolution
1441 under chapter 7 of the U.N Charter
holding that Iraq was a material breach
of its disarmament obligation so let's
keep that straight uh there are ample
legal Arguments for why the war was
legal I'm a lawyer myself I can make
those arguments I won't trouble you with
them let me answer your question yes I
was I represented Iraq in 2004 and for a
number of years thereafter at the United
Nations
um the fact of the matter is that the
United Nations security Council which is
the body we really mean the Secretary
General has no power to stop a member
state from doing anything it's a
security Council by Design the security
Council can only act when there is
unanimity amongst the five permanent
members as your setup piece pointed out
uh the there were only two members who
were advocating for a security Council
resolution reauthorizing the use of
force the other three were against so
that's how the UN is designed just just
a final thought to you uh Faisal how do
you think history then will remember
operation Iraqi freedom I mean this was
the war as you pointed out didn't have
un support they didn't find weapons of
mass destruction yet the U.S led
Coalition still went to war anyway uh on
now discredited intelligence so how will
this Invasion and its aftermath be
remembered do you think
well that's going to be in the eye of
the beholder uh the same is true of
Kosovo uh there was no U.N security
Council authorization for Kosovo
there's absolutely no question that the
Kosovo war was illegal a U.N commission
appointed by Kofi Annan said so although
it called it illegal but legitimate
which is a an incoherent phrase
um and so it's it's how you viewed the
war at the time 20 years later is still
how you're going to view it if things
work out in Iraq history won't ma won't
be bothered by uh the the legal
subtleties of 2003 and Iraq has a 7 000
year history I'm not going to rule it
out after only 20 years Faisal Al Easter
body willing to get your thoughts and
your analysis vital thank you very much
for talking to Al Jazeera thank you sir
my pleasure thank you